porque a gente que é brasileiro a gente
vai falar espanhol a gente pensa que
quando fala mais retard possível tá
parecendo quanto não tá idêntico sou
fluente aí el olhou PR mim e falou assim
Senhor tu apelido e eu não sabia que
apelido em espanhol era nome em
português rapaz galera da escola me
chamava de cabeça de uma coisa que
eu achei estranho lá também é os
cardápios Porque tudo tem umas palavras
que são parece português mas sempre
termina em espanhol ver o cardápio aí
tem isoto de tomate con plumo na Plata
que macarrão a molho Preto Rebelde de c
de m com lute olhava pro moço de é
frango moço frango Eu quero arroz com
frango e feijão Não compreendo rapaz teu
país bem aqui do lado do meu tu não sabe
falar um pouquinho de português me país
do lado do seu seu também do lado do meu
tu também fala ali a minha língua